RUXANDA DANETIU: Thank you
so much for joining us today.
We're going to be talking
about Kubernetes engine
infrastructure and
service oriented
monitoring with Equifax.
My name is Ruxanda.
I'm a product manager
on Google Cloud focused
on cloud monitoring, and today,
my guest is going to be Vipul.
He is a lead SRE at Equifax.
For the next 30
minutes, we're going
to be focusing on
three main topics.
We're going to start by
discussing SLO monitoring
principles.
We're going to do
a Q&A with Vipul
from Equifax to
really understand
how Equifax has adopted SLOs
and the digital transformation
journey that they
are undertaking.
And then at the end, we're
going to have a demo.
Patrick, which is our
engineering lead on cloud
monitoring, is going to
give us a demo of how
we can use SLOs and SLO
monitoring to monitor our GKE
fleet of microservice.
So let's start
thinking a little bit
about what are the principles
behind SLO monitoring?
I know probably many of
you have heard about SLOs,
and when we think
about SLOs, It feels
like we are talking a lot about
numbers and targets and goals.
We talk a lot about how
many 9s that we have
and how important it is to
collect these numbers of 9s,
almost like badges
of [INAUDIBLE]..
We talk about how important
it is for us to have the best
reliability out there,
and a lot of people
really try to strive extensively
to reach that 100% reliability
goal for basically every single
microservice that they own.
And that's what I
want us to start with,
from the point of realizing
that this conversation is not
about numbers.
It's not about getting
every single microservice
to its maximum
availability possible.
And it's 100%-- it's the
wrong target to begin with.
And surprisingly
enough, even though this
is such an incredible
engineering driven experience,
what we were going
to talk about today
is actually language, because
what is more important for us
than anything else
is to figure out
what is a common
language that we can give
every single person
in our organization
the ability to communicate
towards the same success goal.
So let's think about
the business process.
You start with a concept.
You end up building requirements
with your product team,
your marketing team,
your sales teams.
You end up defining the
goal and the business
goal for your product.
You start engaging with
your engineering teams
and build a development
of that product.
You start working and engaging
around your operations teams,
and your operations teams wants
to ensure that what they build,
it's reliable and scalable,
and it's performant.
And then you start taking
the product to market.
The problem is, the way
that I told this story,
is that it feels like this
is set of sequence steps,
and you have to introduce
all of these people
into the process one by one.
But what is important for
us is that we actually
need to have the business, the
development, and the operations
team to collaborate
together on defining
what does success look like for
the organization as a whole.
And when we talk
about success, it
has to be a single metric
that are all of these teams
and all of these
people get behind.
These metrics really need to
reflect what the end customer
experience is all about.
We need to think
about the [INAUDIBLE],,
how the end user
uses our product.
And we need to ensure
that we are building
the right measurement
of that [INAUDIBLE],,
and we make this measurement
understandable and available
to everyone in the organization.
So when we talk about
defining success,
SLOs gives us the ability
to create a common language
across business,
development, and operations
to understand what is
important for the organization
and how to instrument this
into trackable metrics.
Because this is a
common language,
and it's a new language
across the org,
we're going to have
a few new terms we're
going to need to get
familiarized with,
so these are the
three core terms
of service oriented monitoring.
So what is an SLI?
An SLI is a Service
Level Indicator.
Think about this as a
metric under a threshold.
It is a measure of what
success looks or feels like.
An SLO is a Service
Level Objective.
And the difference there,
think about the metric
that you build your SLI on,
and you attach a goal to it.
So you have a fraction of
your successful interactions
that you're interested in.
Let's say you have
a retail website,
and you care about
measuring customer happiness
with your checkout service.
You know that a lot
of your financial team
is really interesting
to make sure
that people can check
out and pay for the items
that they care about, so we
know that is a cornerstone
of the experience.
We know that we want the
service to be available,
but most importantly, we
don't want our customers
to be frustrated.
So here, we're going to start
thinking about how fast do we
want our users to
experience this page,
and it could be a
matter of seconds.
So we need to know
what share of customers
should experience
this, so maybe we
have a target where we can have
a business goal that at least
95% of all of our customers
have to open the checkout cart
service and visualize the data
and the items in [INAUDIBLE]
cart in less than five
seconds, and that is the goal.
So as you can notice we're
not talking about 9s.
We are talking about the
end customer experience,
and that's a really
important clarification
to make as we are thinking about
how to measure the end customer
experience.
And the last item here,
probably all of you
are already familiar with,
because an SLAs is a Service
Level Agreement, and that
takes the SLI, the metric,
attaches the goal,
but then it has
some consequences around it.
So for example,
this is a contract
that you make with your
external customers.
When you tell them that
we have an availability,
our product will be available
for this amount of time
under these
constraints, and if we
don't meet those requirements,
then we will offer you refunds.
So a lot of companies
have implemented
SLAs in these contracts with
their external customers.
What we are trying to
get them to understand
is we already have
the underlying.
Under the SLA, there
is an SLO itself,
and these are really
powerful metrics
that can transform
your organization
and bring your business,
your development,
and your operations into
a single frame of mind.
So now that we have
this new language,
I think it's important
for us to see
what is a great example of
how to take this language
and put it into practice.
And Equifax has been
an incredible advocate
within their own company
of adopting SLOs,
and I am extremely happy
and privileged to have,
today, Vipul join us.
He is an SRE lead
at Equifax, and he's
going to tell us a
little bit about the SLO
journey [INAUDIBLE].
So, Vipul, please
introduce yourself.
Tell us a little
bit about your role,
and tell us a little bit about
the Equifax architecture.
VIPUL MAPARA: Thanks,
Ruxanda, for having me.
It's been a pleasure.
So about my role, I've
been with Equifax 14 years.
Equifax has been great.
I've been started as a
developer 14 years back, served
in various roles, and
then most recently, I've
been working as a SRE for one
of the Alliance data fabric
within Equifax.
A little bit about Equifax--
Equifax is a global company.
We are data analytics
and technology company.
We operate into 24
countries, and the platform
that I'm responsible, my
day to day role as an SRE,
is a enterprise
data lake pattern.
And Equifax is on this digital
transformation journey,
and Google is our platform
of choice to enable us
for the transformation journey.
So as part of that journey,
I'm responsible to implement
the enterprise
data lake pattern.
Primarily, the
capabilities are in just
store, process, analyze, and
server over analytics API.
So probably most of our services
that we leverage from Google
are Kubernetes data flow.
Google helps us to improve
our security posture.
I mean, it's a security first
mindset we have at Equifax,
so Google helps us on that.
And then on operating
tools, we are
using Cloud Logging
and Monitoring
to give us the visibility into
the system set we are running.
So probably that's,
in nutshell, what
we do, and the services and
the capabilities that we
are serving are
pretty much following
the container as the abstraction
and microservice architecture
[INAUDIBLE].
RUXANDA DANETIU: Vipul, you
mentioned microservices.
You know that's going
to be my curiosity.
Please tell me how do
you monitor the health
of your microservices?
VIPUL MAPARA: Great question.
So at the beginning, we were
working off our on-prem data
center, and we didn't have
contain orchestration platform
as part of the infrastructure.
So it was a little hard
to get a visibility
into our applications, and
operations was a little bit
tough.
And also, in our precloud
public cloud [INAUDIBLE],,
our engineering and operations
were working in silos.
So our first approach was, let's
lift and shift our application,
and then progressively moved
to a microservice architecture.
But now that we have
decided to embrace
our digital transformation
with the public cloud,
we are not just
doing lift and shift.
We are really thinking as
rearchitecting the application
and using the
BetterCloud native tools.
The tools that are what
we had in data center
are no more working out
for us, and we really
need a tool which gives us
good observabilitiy into when
we are moving our
applications and workloads
into public cloud.
So if you don't
know, I mean, what
we have to observe
because there's too much
newness about the public cloud.
So what you end up
is you can start
with [INAUDIBLE] on signals.
I mean, as part of
SRE best practice,
to take [INAUDIBLE]
signals and then
work your way towards SLOs.
I mean, I feel that's
a good starting point.
RUXANDA DANETIU: You
mentioned the cloud.
Tell me more a little bit
about the journey behind why
you adopted SLOs,
and what do you think
are the main benefits for
Equifax to start using SLOs?
VIPUL MAPARA: I
mean, SLO a little
has been a great concept
and one of the best practice
that I learned, and
it's a single language
across our engineering team,
product team, marketing,
finance, sales.
It helps us to talk
with a common goal,
so it helps us to
prioritize our effort.
And once we have that
kind of single language
to work across the
organization, it's much better.
Otherwise, you have
a lot of meetings
with analysis paralysis.
You go through a churn, but you
really don't have a direction.
So to give a opinionated meeting
a direction, SLO helps it,
and it really becomes
a data driven decision
that allows us to figure out
where we should prioritize
our efforts and investment.
And also, for SRE,
it is very important.
You know, using SLO as
your guiding principle,
when to wake up and
when to not, and what
really is impacting
the revenue, which
is important for business.
So I feel that's a common
theme that within Equifax
to embrace SLO as
a single language.
RUXANDA DANETIU: It sounds like
there are a lot of benefits.
But be honest with me--
what was the hardest part?
Because this seems
too good to be true.
VIPUL MAPARA: True,
SLO's concept great,
but to put it in execution is
definitely, definitely hard.
The way I articulate
the SLO engagement is,
really, think about
as the overall meal
and not the ingredients.
So when your customer
comes to your restaurant,
they are really expecting
a meal to be served.
They're not really
interested into have
you got the ingredients?
What was the logistics behind
getting all the ingredients so
that you can prepare the meal?
Customer is really
interested in your product.
When you present a product,
what it should look like-- that
is really the focus of it.
And SLO helps you to
measure that exact thing--
what is the feeling
about your product--
and that is the key.
So it's very easy to
focus on the ingredient
and to lose the
focus on the meal,
so that's the
hardest part of it.
Now, what helps us to bring
the focus is the mindset,
and you need the
whole organization
because if you start it just
as an engineering project,
you're going to
have a lot of churn
because you have not brought
your other stakeholders along
with you who has
the say in your SLO.
So that is the other thing-- you
want to focus on the mindset,
and frankly, in Equifax,
we started doing this,
and we brought Google CRE, who
is the Customer Reliability
Engineering crew,
helps us to execute
SRE best practices in Equifax.
So that engagement
also helps us.
RUXANDA DANETIU: So looking
back, this has been a journey.
It didn't happen overnight.
Is there anything that you
would have done differently
knowing what you know today?
VIPUL MAPARA: Well,
for me, personally,
when I took the SRE role, I
wish I knew SRE much earlier.
I did not know much about it, so
I had to do a lot of research.
I had to read some books.
I had to go and do a
lot of reading about it,
because building a
software and a product
that works at a global
scale is not easy.
You really need to have
a engineering mindset
to an operational problem,
and since my background
was as software engineering,
I thought, yes, I
think I can do SRE.
And the other thing I
would have appreciated,
I would have spent more time
learning the cloud native tools
and really be hands on, so I
would feel more comfortable.
But once you get
this concept of SLO
and working with the
engineering mindset
to an operational
problem, and start
learning about concept of SLOs,
I think you will not look back.
I think it's a [INAUDIBLE].
That's what I feel.
RUXANDA DANETIU: I
know there are probably
a lot of people
listening in right now
at the beginning of
their SLO journey.
This is a very intimidating
journey, and I want to know,
can you give them some advice?
What do you think
is really important
to know at the beginning?
VIPUL MAPARA: Very true.
I mean, it is definitely
a hard journey.
I think what worked
for us, probably
I can say about a
little bit, start small.
Think about SLO concepts
in error budget concepts.
Really learn about
those concepts.
Decide how you want
to get started.
Have socialized SLO concepts
within the organization.
Bring your stakeholders
along with you,
and then figure out a small
pilot where you would really
try to implement a critical
journey on an SLO around there.
Once you do that, I
think it helps you.
And Google CRE helps us
to navigate stakeholders,
how to present the
view around it,
but I would start small on it.
Once you have that small pilot
project with a blueprint,
with some of the
best practices of SLO
and error budget
concept baked into it,
the next thing
you would get into
is pick up the right tools.
You need the right tools
to achieve this scale of,
how do you implement SLO.
Frankly, I mean, in GCP,
the [INAUDIBLE] signals are
available out of the box,
so you could literally
take those [INAUDIBLE]
signals and instrument those
and build your SLA out of it.
And Google has a product,
Google Cloud Monitoring SLO API,
to allow us to build SLOs
out of those [INAUDIBLE]..
So we started doing that
for the first pilot.
It gave us a single
view for our pilot,
and then from that blueprint, we
started replicating and moving
other services to
follow the things.
And iteratively, we had
all of our services managed
through Cloud Monitoring,
and we had a single view
of all of our SLOs that were
important to our stakeholders.
And it became a overall
organizational ecosystem
that SRE manages and
works [INAUDIBLE]..
That's how I feel, if you start
small and pick the right tools
and have Cloud Monitoring SLO
API as your tools behind it,
I think it'll help.
RUXANDA DANETIU:
Thank you, Vipul,
for sharing your personal story.
That was really meaningful.
I know that there are a lot of
people listening in right now
at the beginning of
their SLO journey.
Is there any advice
that you would
give somebody that's
starting that SLO
journey for the first time?
VIPUL MAPARA: Definitely.
I think, at Equifax, SLO
has been a journey for us.
I would suggest start small.
Really understand the SLO
and the error budget concept,
because once you
understand the concept,
then you can decide
on how to get started.
I would advise
research internally,
bring the stakeholders
along with you,
and then identify a small pilot.
Figure out the critical journeys
that goes along with the pilot,
and build the SLOs around them.
Also, get some help
from Google CRE,
who can help you to navigate the
SRE best practices on building
SLOs, so that way the
blueprint that you're building
is reused for other services.
Once you have a
pilot identified,
and you have defined your
critical user journeys,
which you wanted to
define SLO around,
the next topic is really about
pick the right tools that
supports that, and
the beauty of GCP
is they support
[INAUDIBLE] signals out
of the box at Google Cloud.
So that makes building the
SLO as soon as possible,
because you can use
[INAUDIBLE] signals
and start building your SLO.
Once you get into the SLO, you
can use Google Cloud Monitoring
SLO API, which allows
you to build SLOs,
and then you get all your
SLOs in a single view.
And I think, with
those two points,
I feel it's a great start.
RUXANDA DANETIU: Thank
you so much, Vipul,
for taking the time
to talk to me today
and for sharing such a
meaningful story of your SLO
adoption at Equifax.
VIPUL MAPARA: Thank you.
It's a pleasure.
RUXANDA DANETIU: So next,
let's take one example.
Let's think about SLO
monitoring for your GKE fleet.
And what I want us
to take a step back
is to understand that the SLO
monitoring functionality really
does not depend on the
underlying infrastructure
that you are deploying.
So within Google Cloud, we
have out of the box integration
for every single
platform available.
So if you're using GKE
or Compute Engine or App
Engine or any
other GCP products,
you would be able to create
SLOs in that environment.
We have built curated,
out of the box experience
for the [INAUDIBLE]
this product as well.
However, if you have a
multi-cloud deployment
or running on
premise environments
as well, if you're
bringing in your metrics
into the back end
of Cloud Monitoring,
we will be able
to create and help
you set up your
SLOs with our API
very easily on those
environments as well,
even if they are Kubernetes
or virtual machines
or other clouds.
And when we talk about
scale, SLO monitoring
is really build on the scale of
the entire GCP console back end
for both monitoring and logging.
This is the same back end that
operates internal Google as
well, and our SLO API is
currently used internally
at Google, but it's also used
by our external cloud customers.
Everything gets built with
zero config from day one,
and it gives you all
of the observability.
So there are a lot
of the [INAUDIBLE]
that Vipul mentioned and a lot
of metrics that come in out
of the box and get added
to the product for you
to be able to create
your SLOs very easily.
All of the functionality that
we are talking about in terms
of SLO monitoring at
scale, both the UI and API,
they are in general
availability as of today,
so we're really happy to
make this functionality
available to all
of our customers.
And in order to showcase
the UI experience,
Patrick Ethan, the
engineering lead
that have helped build the UI
and the API for SLO monitoring,
is going to give
us a whirlwind tour
of how to do SLO monitoring
for your GKE environment.
Take it away, Patrick.
PATRICK ETHAN: Hello.
Today, I would like
to introduce you
to the service oriented
monitoring and SLO monitoring
features in GCP's Cloud
Monitoring product.
These features are currently
in general availability.
First, I want to
draw your attention
to the workspace selector
in the upper left.
A workspace is a
concept that allows
one to combine multiple
projects into a single view.
This is great for
being able to view
an entire fleet of services
in a single pane of glass.
Next, notice that
we're in the monitoring
menu and the services sub
menu of the cloud console.
The first view you'll
see in the services area
is the service inventory
or services overview page.
On this page, we see a list
of all of the microservices
that have been detected
or identified by the user.
You can see that there's a
number of different types
of services that depends
on the technology that's
used to develop those services.
We currently support GAE,
Cloud Endpoints, [INAUDIBLE]
and GKE, Anthos
Service Mesh, and what
we're going to focus on today,
GKE based microservices.
In order to
understand these more,
let's start by defining
a GKE microservice.
When we click Define Service,
we see that the tray slides out
with a list of all
of the GKE entities
that are in the workspace,
including deployments, replica
sets, Kubernetes services,
namespaces, and so on.
Depending on the model that
your organization uses,
any of these entities
could be a microservice.
Now, I know that the way
that my organization works,
deployments are what
correspond to microservices,
and I also know, from
discussions with my broader
organization, including
PM and eng in operations,
that the ad service
is a service that
requires particular attention.
So we search for ad
service and find out
there's actually two of them
running in our workspace.
We'll select one of them, give
them a name, click Submit,
and with that, we've created the
first GKE based microservice.
Next, you can read more
about best practices
for monitoring services at
the documentation link here,
or you can move directly
to creating a service level
objective.
Instead, we're going to
go back to the inventory
and notice that our new
microservice appears
in the inventory already.
It includes the
metadata labels that
are used to define
the microservice,
including the cluster name,
CSM demo, and the deployment ad
service.
It also indicates that we
don't have any SLOs or SLO
based alerts yet.
If we click into the dashboard
for the service itself,
at the top of that, we see that
the first piece of monitoring
data is about SLOs.
This is granted space
at the top of the page
because SLOs are one of the most
valuable things for monitoring
services.
Now, we don't yet
have any silos,
so let's fix that
by creating an SLO.
Again, this
describes the service
that we're creating
the SLO alert for.
Some service types have
default availability or latency
metrics, but we're going
to pick our own metric.
Now, there are a
number of metrics
that are available out
of the box for all users
to define SLOs.
For example, here is a
list of container metrics
that may be useful
for defining SLOs.
GCLBs also have a number of
metrics which can be useful.
As the developer of
this app, however, I
know that the thing
that best reflects
the performance
of the ad service
is the response latency metric.
Based on discussions
with PM and others,
I know that customers
are satisfied
with the ad service when it
responds in 30 milliseconds
or less on any of the containers
that are running that image.
Once we describe the
metric that we're
going to use to
evaluate the SLO,
we can see a preview of how that
metric is actually performing,
and we can also guess that
30 milliseconds is actually
a pretty aggressive target
given the behavior of the system
right now.
To finish defining the SLO,
we set the compliance period
to be a calendar week and
a performance goal of 90%.
What that means is that 90% of
all requests to the ad service
need to finish in
30 milliseconds
in order to be compliant.
Finally, we give it a
name, we click Submit,
and now we've created
our first SLO.
We can evaluate the SLO based
on the historical behavior
of the system, so we
don't have to wait
for history to accumulate.
We can see that, right now,
the service level indicator,
the metric, is
running at about 95%,
which is greater
than our 90% target.
We can also see that about
half of the error budget
is remaining for the week.
If we expand the time
selector out to a week,
we can see that, indeed, at
the beginning of the week,
the error budget resets
and then trails off
as the week progresses.
Based on last week, it
looks like we will run out
of error budget,
so there's probably
some reliability work that needs
to be done for this service.
Notice, also, that
there is a view
to look at SLO based alerts that
are firing for this service.
In order to create these,
you can use this link here,
and that alert can be
created right in context.
The SLO based alerts
are based on the concept
of a fast burn alert, which
means that the system can
detect when the error budget is
being burned at a rate that's
not sustainable, and such
that the system can remain
in compliance.
If we look at other parts
of the service dashboard,
we can see that the metrics
widget is interesting.
It contains a lot of the
out of the box metrics
that are available
to users arranged
in a number of bundles.
It's currently seeing
the container metrics
corresponding to CPU.
We can also look
at, for example,
pod level metrics
on network usage.
We select that, and
the charts update.
We can see individual pods and
the network usage on those.
Alternatively, we can look
at a node metric such as CPU
to see what kind of
capacity our cluster has.
If we scroll down further, we
can see the Kubernetes pods
that make up this service.
Here, we see we have five pods
running the ad service right
now.
All of them are ready and
running, so they're healthy.
For each of them, resource
utilization is described,
and under the
snowman, we see a link
to the Kubernetes engine page.
If we switch to the Kubernetes
part of the cloud console,
this is where we can
see more information
about the pod, including
its events, its logs,
and also take actions on the
pod such as restarting it.
The last part of the service
dashboard is the logs widget.
This widget gives
a brief overview
of the logs that are being
emitted by the microservice.
If, however, we want to look
at the logs in more detail,
we can go to the logs viewer.
Now, the interesting thing
about pivoting to the log viewer
is that the context,
or the filter state,
for the microservice
is preserved.
You can see here that
the filter, by default,
goes to the cluster that we've
been monitoring and the ad
service.
Even the timestamp
filter is brought across
to the logs viewer
to preserve context.
The logs viewer shows a
histogram of log volume.
It also facets it by severity.
We can filter to errors,
to the error severity,
and very quickly get to the
stack traces corresponding
to our microservice.
Now, let's return to the
idea of SLO based alerts.
If we go to the
overview, we can see
that there are three SLO based
alerts that are currently
firing.
If we filter to those services,
we see that one of them
is the default GKE namespace.
Let's look at what a service
level dashboard looks like when
there are incidents firing.
The thing you'll
notice different
is that now there is an
alert timeline at the top.
The timeline indicates
when incidents
are firing by the red
bars on the timeline.
If you hover on these
bars, you see a summary
of the corresponding
alert along with a link
to get the alert details.
The alert timeline can also
be used as a time selector,
and when you select
the time there,
that also updates the
time for all the charts
and for all the log entries.
You should also notice that
this default microservice has
two SLOs defined, so you
can have more than one SLO
defined for a single service.
You can also have more than one
alert defined for a single SLO.
That completes a tour of the UI
for service oriented monitoring
and SLOs.
You should note that if
you're interested in managing
large numbers of
services or SLOs,
there is an API that's also
available that allows access
to all of these features.
It has been my
pleasure to introduce
you to service oriented
monitoring concepts today
in Cloud Monitoring.
Thank you.
RUXANDA DANETIU: Thank
you so much, Patrick,
for the insightful demo.
I really appreciate
the work that
went into building the product
and putting the demo together.
I want to share also special
thanks to the Equifax team
that has been one of our
lead users of SLO monitoring,
and many other
GCP customers that
are already using this
product in production today.
I want to also thank the CRE
team, the Cloud Reliability
Engineering team at Google,
for using the SLO monitoring
product as a best practice for
adopting SRE best practices
to our organizations.
I'm really happy that
the product is finally
in general availability,
and please give it a try.
If you want to learn more about
other cloud operations sessions
and learn about all
of the work that we're
doing on Cloud Monitoring
and Cloud Logging,
these are the available talks.
Thank you so much for your time.